are you guys doing good rain I was gonna
say um I want to give credit to
Universal on the amazing matte painting
it's really the movement is what really
gets me you know Graham it's absolutely
uh I know you're a huge Richard Curtis
fan and apparently you can quote dialog
so I guess my big question is what did
you pay to be in the movie a lot of
money for both of you actually I'm
curious when you go in at some point
you're going to meet Danny Boyle you're
going to meet Richard Curtis to talk
about something like this what let's go
in through your mind the night before
you're gonna go for that meeting knowing
this could like you know you might be
part of this really cool project
I mean hey oh my god oh my god oh my god
like over and over and over and and just
yeah but like nerves i how am I gonna am
I gonna get it right but I just had to
kind of like throw that away when I was
going into the room cuz you know really
privileged things to go and meet Danny
me and Richard and spend time with him
seeing Beatles some sort of kind of like
just motor that's going to and enjoy it
oh I was I mean I knew Richard because
of Mamma Mia and that was the first deal
that I made
and then and so I was so anti new and I
saw I just loved the script the scenes
are so easy to do because the dialogue
is so easy and brilliant and then Danny
just like totally blew me away because I
know if this incredible incredible
filmmaker in his music as a person in
the room how he behaves with actors and
people like it's up on his feet with
walk around the room we were doing the
scenes it was so playful so energetic
and I just I walked out I just thought
to get this role I have to work with
these guys the next three months I have
to and so I was really happy when I
think one of the things that I really
appreciate about Richard's work is he he
he makes these really good feel-good
movies you know he just like brings his
positive energy into the world and sort
of could you sort of talk about like the
movie has that sort of you know what I
mean like you you feel good yeah and
that does come from Richard I think you
know he's lovely and he's very generous
and it's his family is so generous as
well like you know we stayed very close
to his family when we were filming in
self booking like they're just they're
so welcoming and and about love and then
that's why his films are imbued with
that because he's he is that he is that
person
he spends history if he's not doing
something for us he's doing something
for the UN you know I mean he's just an
amazing guy and you like creates
momentum doesn't need through the movie
that like you're swept into it and so
you you can't you eat sometimes you know
if there's a movie on you go I'll just
watch 20 minutes of this no it's rich
guys for I will watch it till the end
and I will because you you pot you get
sucked in and that's incredible
I was thinking that actually when I left
the theater I'm like this is gonna be a
movie out i rewatch it becomes I know
what I mean it's one of those kind of
films absolutely uh so before the
filming begins you're looking at the
script you're seeing everything you have
to do for the two of you well is there
one senior like Oh F this is gonna be a
real challenge a challenge the rooftop
Pier Hotel that was like one for me I
was like and then they told me are we
actually gonna get 5,000 people it was
like oh great
but then it obviously it was great it
was one of the best experiences I've
ever had but it was it was
nerve-wracking I always I always like
worried about the emotional crunches of
the movie because I just I I really want
to nail them
because they're important they're like
the anchors and so you know the true
political life she train station was the
scene that I was apprehensive about but
in a good way but III that one was that
felt like it very important I already
have to stop I'm just gonna say congrats
on the movie you both did such a great
job thank you very much and good luck
with the rest of the day